Eugene
congratulations
thank you
he was too tired
I think I just drive around
um
thank you
because of course in America
I said
yeah
attention the price briefing will begin
in two minutes the Press briefing will
begin in two minutes
foreign
conversation
energy
together
um
foreign
good afternoon everybody
okay
So today we're joined by Secretary of
Education Miguel Cardona and Deputy NEC
director Bharat ramamadi they're here to
speak about the Supreme Court's decision
on the student debt relief this morning
and as you all know you just heard from
the president and uh so before we get we
go there I just want to talk about a few
things at the top and then we'll I'll
hand it over to our two guests first we
are deeply disappointed in the Supreme
Court's decision today in 303 creative
which takes our nation backward in the
fight for equality
this decision undermines the basic truth
that no American should face
discrimination for who they are or who
they love and it's even more
disappointing as we close out pride
month today it chips away at a
long-standing laws that protect all
Americans against this termination and
public accommodations including people
of color
people with disabilities and people of
faith and women
while the Court's decision only
addresses expressive original designs as
President Biden said today we are
concerned that the decision could invite
more discrimination against the lgbtq
plus community
and we know that when one group's
dignity and equality are threatened the
promise of our democracy is threatened
and we all suffer the administration
will remain focused on enforcing Federal
anti-discrimination protections and the
president will continue to call on
Congress to pass the equality act now
second as we head into July 4th the
Department of Transportation and the FAA
are working closely with Airlines to
help minimize flight disruptions
resulting from extreme weather Airline
operations quickly recovered from the
weather earlier this week except for
United Airlines which expects to return
to normal tomorrow but we will continue
to keep a close eye on all of this and
we want to remind our travelers to visit
flightrights.gov again that's
flightrights.gov to see what you're
entitled to if your flight is canceled
or delayed finally as you
a pool note in a couple of hours before
the end of the day for sure but before I
move on I want to acknowledge someone in
the room who you all know very well and
who has been a friendly face to all of
you and to all of us that is Ed Lewis Ed
is retiring today after 25 years as
photographer for Fox News and 14 years
at C-SPAN
foreign
[Applause]
in his career Ed has covered every
president since Ronald Reagan right not
to Aid you my friend
you look young 21. I know he is a friend
who many of folks here and it's
certainly many folks on my team he
always has a smile every time I see him
he always waves smiles and gives me a
thumbs up so I give you a thumbs up back
to you my friend and I know many of you
have seen him traveling carrying like 13
bags or something like that all at once
so incredibly impressive so Ed thank you
for being a joy to work with I hope you
are in you will enjoy more time at the T
following your last day here and we will
truly truly miss you and thank you for
just always being a friendly face we do
the team decided to get you something so
here you go
can you step away for a second or do I
have to come back
actually
[Applause]
first
sorry first time ever anything like this
oh and you're very welcome very excited
okay so now I'm going to turn it over to
a secretary Cardona who's going to say a
few words about the plan that the
president announced today after the
Supreme Court decision and then of
course Barat as you know is here to take
any questions as well Mr secretary
good afternoon
in the last 48 hours our country has
been set back in terms of providing
equity and access in higher education
and as you heard from the president
today the Supreme Court ruled against
more than 40 million Working Families
let's be clear about who would have
benefited from the president's student
debt relief plan
nearly 90 percent of relief would have
gone to borrowers making less than 75
000 a year
20 million Americans would see their
debts drop to zero with 20 million more
seeing lower payments
this would mean fewer borrowers falling
into the delinquency and default when
payment pause ended
we're not talking about the millionaires
who benefited from the billions in tax
giveaways a few years ago we're talking
about low and middle income families
recovering from the worst pandemic in a
century I strongly disagree with the
Court's decision here so today I want to
assure our students our borrowers and
families Across America our fight is not
over
we're taking action
the president the vice president and I
have put borrowers first from day one
we refuse to go back to the way things
were before the pandemic when a million
borrowers defaulted each year and faced
devastating Financial consequences so
let me tell you about the actions we're
taking today number one
we're going to open up an alternative
path to debt relief for as many
Borrowers
as possible as quickly as possible
but we acknowledge the Court's decision
we began the negotiated rulemaking
process on settlement and compromise
Authority today
more information
on the new regulations will come out
shortly number two today we are rolling
out the most affordable income driven
repayment plan ever
this new plan is called saving on a
valuable education save
it'll cut monthly payments in half
for all undergraduate loans it'll cut
payments to zero dollars for millions of
people making less than thirty three
thousand dollars a year
all other borrowers will save at least a
thousand dollars per year
this plan will stop runaway interests
and it's not going to require you to pay
more than you can afford
and number three
as a president as the president
mentioned we're creating an on-ramp for
repayment
for up to one year for those who need it
this means although interest will accrue
starting September 1st and payments are
due starting October we'll help
borrowers who are struggling to make
payments avoid harsh Financial
consequences such as delinquencies and
wage garnishments
borrowers who can make payments should
again I disagree with today's decision
from the Supreme Court
today the court substituted itself for
Congress
it's outrageous to me that republicans
in Congress and State offices fought so
hard against a program that would have
helped millions of their own
constituents
they had no problem handing trillion
dollar tax cuts to Big corporations in
the super wealthy and many had no
problems accepting millions of dollars
in forgiven pandemic loans
like Senator Mark Wayne Mullen from
Oklahoma had more than 1.4 million
dollars in pandemic loans forgiven he
represents 489 000 eligible borrowers
that were turned down today
representative Brett Guthrie from
Kentucky had more than 4.4 million
dollars forgiven
he represents more than 90 000 eligible
borrowers who were turned down today
representative Marjorie Taylor Green
from Georgia had more than 180 thousand
dollars forgiven she represents more
than 91 800 eligible borrowers who were
turned down today
I want all the students and borrowers to
know President Biden vice president
Harris and I will not stop fighting for
you
you should be able to earn a college
education without student debt blocking
you from opportunity
that's why we're fixing a broken system
we're protecting the Next Generation by
increasing College accountability fixing
Public service loan forgiveness and
going after predatory College in
addition to increasing Pell Grants
today we've approved more than 66
billion dollars in targeted loan
forgiveness and we're not going to stop
fighting
we cannot allow the setbacks of
yesterday and today to stop us from
reimagining A Better Tomorrow one in
which all students
from different income levels and racial
backgrounds have access to Affordable
Pathways to College and Career thank you
I'm sorry
the higher education access and it seems
like if if the heroes Act was on legally
footing this might be even more so and
if if you're more secure that this is a
legal route to do it why didn't you just
use this in the first place we believe
the Supreme Court got it wrong today we
believe the heroes act does give me the
authority the Supreme Court made their
decision today we accept that The Higher
Education Act has a pathway and we're
going to use that pathway if you think
that's a better way to do it why didn't
you just use that in the first time we
believe that the heroes act pathway was
quicker and we had the authority to do
that
the president said that this new would
take some time that it will take longer
how long are you expecting it to take
and you also mentioned that more details
will be rolled out when will that be
happening sure so it is a regulatory
process and I'll turn it over to my
colleague uh brought in a second but
that process does take longer as the
president said which is why we started
with the heroes act we have to believe
we have the authority and we were ready
to act and it was stopped through a
lawsuit right when we were going to
provide the debt relief
sure
so the The Higher Education Act
rulemaking is goes through What's called
the negotiated rulemaking process that's
actually different than your typical
rulemaking process as you all know even
a typical rulemaking process can take
some amount of time you have to do a
proposal it has to receive comments it
has to be finalized and so on the
negotiated rulemaking process Again by
law
is even more uh complicated than that in
that there needs to be public hearings
that involve back and forth with
relevant stakeholders relevant members
of the public so it's going to take some
amount of time what you heard from the
president today was that we are
committed to moving as quickly as
possible to get through all of those
steps till we get a final proposal and
it's indicative of that that the
secretary in just the hours between when
the Supreme Court issued its opinion and
to the end right now has already
initiated that process has already filed
the necessary paperwork to get it going
but
certainly not weeks it's going to be
months
as I said even the typical rulemaking
process typically takes months but we
are aiming to do it as quickly as
possible and so we will give you more
updates as we hit each milestone in that
process I don't know if the secretary
mentioned this but the first step is
going to be a public hearing that's
going to happen in July so that's going
to get the ball rolling beyond what we
did today and the president said that
this new plan is legally sound how did
you reach this conclusion did you do an
analysis or what attack lawyers from the
Department of Education from the White
House from the Department of Justice all
reviewed this plan they weighed in and
believed that it was legally available I
should be clear that they did the same
for the heroes act and obviously we ran
into a supreme court that had a
different view of things frankly a view
that we believe is out of step with
where the law is but we have the backing
of all of the relevant attorneys here
from the attorney from the Department of
Justice from the Department of Education
and from the White House all believing
that this is a valid Pathway to
providing debt relief to many Borrowers
number of Americans who would have
benefited under the previous plan
benefit under this pathway is it a
smaller number is it a bigger number
well one of the things about the
rulemaking process is that we can't
actually prejudge its outcome part of
how we do this process is that we
initiate it we put a proposal on the
table we work with stakeholders to get
their input that ends up shaping the
scope of The Proposal so it's too early
to say but we have clear guidance from
the president and the secretary that our
goal is to provide relief to as many
borrowers as possible under this process
so you'll hear more about that as we get
to each stage of the process going
forward
it's too too early to say
um I had a question on the 12 months
it's not a pause but what is going to
happen in the interim for people who are
uh impacted by the decision sure so it
you're right it's not a pause uh what
we're what we're uh communicating to to
Borrowers is you know the interest will
start accruing and the payments are due
and if you're able to pay pay but we're
not going to be uh you know sending
information to to Credit Agencies or
having folks go into delinquency three
years have passed
43 million Americans were waiting today
for a decision and a little bit of help
and the Supreme Court shut that down
what I want to tell Borrowers is this
on-ramp is intended to support you make
it back to repayment with dignity and
back on your feet we want to prevent
delinquencies we want to prevent
defaults that's why we did this targeted
loan forgiveness in the first place so
this on-ramp is not a loan pause it is a
process through which we're going to
support our borrowers by uh not
um you know sending information to
Credit Agencies if they're if they're
missing a payment but we're encouraging
uh payment to be made and interest will
be accruing in the process the process
on the new rule making takes longer than
12 months would you be willing to extend
this Beyond a year you know from day one
um the president vice president and the
Department of Education has been focused
on getting more students into higher
education and making sure that higher
education doesn't mean a lifetime of
debt where people can't buy homes or
have children are discouraged from being
public servants that's what we're
focusing on so we're going to take it uh
this step is going to be a 12-month
process we're going to make sure we're
communicating with borrowers clearly and
we're going to make it as smooth as
possible for repayment
this Administration was very confident
that the heroes act would work of course
the Supreme Court blocked that why
should borrowers trust you this time
that this one will work there has been
no other president that has done more to
fight for uh student debt relief to
fight to make higher education more
accessible look I was a classroom
teacher I was a district leader I had
too many conversations with parents who
thought College Was Out Of Reach for
their kids
and in the last 48 hours these two
decisions from scotus make me want to
fight harder to make sure that we're
giving them opportunities opportunities
like I had as a first generation college
student there are too many people
watching right now that are worried that
they're not going to be able to access
college or that they're not going to be
able to afford it with the save plan the
income driven repayment plan with the
on-ramp and with the processes that
we're going to take we're doing
everything we can to fight for our
students and to give them the
opportunity to access higher education
um the lawyers that you're saying
believe that this path is sound
um you know this this path could face
the same chord right
um as the previous plan
so given that the lawyers got the
outcome wrong the last time with the
court that we have
um
how is this going to impact you know
biodynamics and the central piece of the
2024 Campaign which has hinged on this
forgiveness plan and and people
believing that it's possible what has
changed the court isn't changing so what
right what's changing so I'll let uh
brought answer that about the bionomics
and the long-term impact but we're going
to fight we're going to keep fighting
and there were many other legal Scholars
that believe we had the Authority Under
the heroes act I mean the heroes act
makes it pretty clear I have the
authority to modify or wave the Supreme
Court saw it differently we're moving
forward in another path and we're going
to put the best legal argument forward
to provide uh relief for borrowers
that's our focus and we're not going to
stay off of that
important
challenge we're going to keep fighting
and we're going to put the best legal uh
argument forward to to stand up for
borrowers and to keep fighting uh for
affordable college did you want to talk
about a bigger plan sure
but I just want to add one one thing on
on that question it's we're just
beginning the rulemaking process now
there's going to be time to craft the
exact proposal under this new legal
Authority you know one thing of course
that we'll keep in mind is how this plan
is going to be received by the courts
but what the president believes is that
if his lawyers who are all highly
qualified attorneys tell him that a path
is legally available he's going to trust
them and we're going to put our best
foot forward in court to defend it what
I would say to Borrowers is that we are
taking action on multiple fronts to help
them in light of the Supreme Court
opinion today there's the 12-month
on-ramp to repayment which is going to
be a real benefit to borrowers who may
be having trouble getting started again
on their repayments and who may have to
skip or payment or two because they need
to get their financial situation
together previously they may have been
put into delinquency or default or seen
a negative mark on their credit report
we're going to make sure that doesn't
happen for the first 12 months so that's
a real benefit to those borrowers and as
secretary said I don't want people
sleeping on this this income-based
repayment plan that we're rolling out
today that was finalized is a huge deal
it is going to save the typical borrower
a thousand dollars a year on their loan
repayments
uh somebody who is making fifty sixty
thousand dollars a year is going to see
a substantial savings and may even end
up paying zero dollars in their monthly
payment because of these new this new
program and by the way one concern that
people have had about the income-based
repayment program in the past is that if
you're making these smaller payments
your balance would keep growing over
time one of the reforms we're putting in
place is making sure that that balance
doesn't grow over time even as you're
making potentially a zero dollar payment
each month it is a big deal for both
current borrowers and for all the future
borrowers who are out there now I want
to be clear that's not a substitute for
debt relief but it is a huge benefit for
borrowers that is going to be available
coming this summer and we encourage
people to sign up for it
throughout the
the sounds good on Instagram are you
because
the deduct the regulatory process short
deadlines way being the typical public
comment requirements well there are
requirements that are laid out in the
law that we have to follow
but we are committed to doing those
requirements as quickly as we possibly
can while keeping with the spirit of the
law like I said we have to do these
public hearings there has to be a
certain amount of preparation to do the
public hearings you have to intake the
comments that you get from the public
and then you have to decide whether to
change your proposal accordingly before
you do the next public hearing all of
that takes some amount of time but as
the secretary made clear as the
president made clear we are doing that
as quickly as we possibly can
starting with the fact that we've
already initiated the process today in
just the handful of hours since the
Supreme Court issued its opinion has the
administration considered an executive
order that would lower interest rates
for these Federal governments we looked
at a number of possibilities the
president's direction to us was to look
at all available legal authorities to
figure out what we can do to provide
relief to borrowers the specific
proposal that you discussed was not the
one that we went with eventually we
think that this pathway that we have
laid out here is the fastest way to
provide the relief to the most amount of
borrowers and so that's what we're going
with now we think it's legally available
and we look forward to providing that
relief to borrowers as soon as this
process is done
that Authority is Crystal Clear there's
a specific statute allowing the
secretary to design these income-based
repayment programs and the specific
details of this income-based repayment
program are clearly within what's
permitted under the statute there and so
we I would be surprised frankly if there
was a legal challenge to that proposal
um you say it's not a substitute
obviously for debt uh forgiveness
um are there I think this is a known
answer so I'm sorry for even asking it
but like how big is the universe of
people who don't qualify for the
income-based repayment who just aren't
going to be covered by this exciting
thing you just offered every single
borrower is eligible for this program
now the key is that if you're an
extremely high income borrower
your income may be so high that the
specific benefit where you cap your
payment at a percentage of your income
doesn't actually benefit you because
that percentage is still higher than
what your monthly payment would be but
it stretches pretty far far up the
income Spectrum so that the kinds of
folks who are eligible for the initial
debt relief program we're talking about
people making seventy five eighty
thousand dollars a year are certainly
going to benefit from this
recording
several opinions that I know have
tripped up by the administration
policies over the last couple of years
can you talk about how you see this
opinion moving forward applying in other
areas of policy making that you do
well look I I think that um it's kind of
in the eye of Beholder right when when
the heroes act says that the secretary
can waive or modify a provision
it seems to me that that is very clear
about what the secretary's authorities
are it is a broad grant of authority
from Congress that I was expecting the
secretary to be acting in an emergency
situation there's also a very broad
grant of authority in The Higher
Education Act which talks about the
secretary having the ability to settle
or compromise debts so uh look I think
that even the Supreme Court would say
that this Doctrine is evolving it is
something that was invented very
recently and it has already changed in
our view in this opinion compared to the
last opinion in which it came up so
we'll need to keep an eye on it but from
where it stands now we think that the
settlement and compromise pathway that
Higher Education Act pathway that we
talked about today is going to be a
valid pathway that conforms with the
major questions Doctrine issue that the
Supreme Court raised today
this Doctrine continuing to be an
obstacle to two different goals that we
have moving forward
well it seems to be intended to place
restrictions on what the executive
branch can do in certain situations even
when in our view Congress speaks clearly
about what the executive branch can and
can't do so we have to take that at face
value and as we evaluate the
availability of certain administrative
actions going forward we'll have to
weigh how it would stand up against that
new doctrine that the Supreme Court has
issued but again we think that the
pathway that we're choosing here The
Higher Education Act is available even
with this Doctrine in place
the secretary Cardona are you
considering potentially raising the
income threshold for those zero dollar
monthly payments on the idrs or is that
33 000 annual number set in stone
henceforth it is uh 33 000 and and I
want to make it very clear that folks
are paying attention to this that maybe
don't know the details of it the income
driven repayment plan that we talked
about today save we're calling it save
um we'll cut in half
loan payments for undergraduate students
so think about the students that said I
can't go to college because I can't
afford the 600 700 those are going to be
cut in half it's going to open doors to
higher education for folks making less
than thirty three thousand dollars which
is your question uh their threshold uh
the threshold of payment is higher than
the 33 000. so if you're making less
than 33 000 you won't have a payment
arrests or who's going to be monitoring
whether people are still making that
number moving forward
did you want to take care yeah
yeah as part of the program you have to
submit your tax return so it monitors it
on an annual basis
and I think there's actually an
obligation that if your income changes
significantly you have to provide an
update
from a practical perspective the
millions have already applied to the
program that now has been blocked that I
notice the president was encouraging
people to still sign up so is the
thinking that that could just be
transferred to the new regulation once
that's set up or how will that work yeah
again I know this is not particularly
satisfying but it is too early to say
because we haven't completed the
rulemaking process yet it is clearly the
case that you know just the a handful of
days I think maybe a little bit over a
week that the website was available we
had an incredible Rush of interest you
had 16 million people go to the website
fill out the form and indicate that they
were eligible for debt relief you know
as the president's remarks made clear
today he certainly feels for all of the
40 million borrowers but especially
those 16 million who went through the
process and got a notification saying
you you are going to get your debt
relief only to have Republican officials
and and the courts step in and block
that but uh but no it's not it's too
it's premature to say whether those
people are necessarily going to be at
the front of the line or anything like
that in a new uh process for months the
White House had said they felt confident
the law being on their side but then
also of course you guys were preparing
different scenarios as we've now learned
so what were you bracing for today how
surprised were you both about this
outcome or is this really what you
expected given some of the work that was
put into the contingency look let me
read the the secretary has the right to
waive or modify any statutory or
regulatory provision uh in the form
deemed appropriate by the secretary to
offset National Emergency
that was
the legal Authority what I want to
remind folks is we got a decision from
scotus I thought I think it's a wrong
decision 43 million people were waiting
for for some relief like some uh others
have gotten in the form of PPP loan
forgiveness that didn't happen within
hours we started the regulatory process
we're not going to stop fighting This
president's been very clear the vice
president's been very clear we're going
to put borrowers first we're going to
put students first
and the president made someone made
reference to uh when the president asked
folks to go online Public service loan
forgiveness went from 7 000 people from
2017 to 2021 we're at 600 000 people now
in two years we're fighting for students
we're fighting fighting for Access for
higher education we're going to continue
to do that and we're going to do that
we're going to do that based on uh legal
footing we recognize that this decision
today we had a really very carefully to
make sure we know which path we're going
to go forward but the bottom line is the
president is going to continue to fight
we're going to continue to fight higher
education should be accessible to more
people and that's what we're going to be
fighting for thank you the secretary has
to
do you mind staying just for a couple
more questions and then
thank you thank you very much so much
okay yes uh thank you Kareem um question
the Democrats like to distinguish
themselves as being different than
Republicans in terms of this specific
law for example uh but really neither
side is doing anything about the runaway
cause of higher education nobody is
really doing anything I mean this belief
doesn't do anything for future students
so it's either party really any
different are you are Democrats not uh
just essentially as dishonest in their
approach as they accuse the other side
of being in terms of the impact that
they would have on students going
forward neither both both parties are
really beholden to the Wall Street
beneficiaries of of these runaway
interest rates and these runaway debts
what are Democrats willing to do about
the runaway costs of Education that
really is at the heart of the matter no
I think it's a real problem that's one
of the reasons why when the president
announced his plan last August when he
announced his debt relief plan there was
another key provision in there which was
a set of policy ideas about holding
colleges accountable for raising prices
it was a set of reforms that we were
putting in place to make sure exactly
what you said that colleges can't get
away with continuing to raise tuition
costs for students so that the ability
to go to to go to college is Out Of
Reach for your typical middle-class
family the Department of Education has
already made progress on What's called
the gainful employment rule which would
restrict whether Federal loans can be
used at a particular school if they
aren't showing that people are
graduating from that school and getting
higher incomes when they graduate it's a
significant update to that rule that is
going to hold colleges accountable for
actually delivering on the promise of
higher education for those students and
I would also note that the president was
able to secure the single largest
increase in the Pell grant that we've
had in the history of this country so
that people like he said who make uh in
almost every instance under sixty
thousand dollars a year people from
families making sixty thousand dollars a
year or less get that additional bump
which is going to open up the doors for
higher education for them so we're
trying to come at this from both ends
we're trying to help lower income
middle-income families afford the cost
of college by providing some direct
relief and we're holding colleges
accountable so they can't keep raising
prices while delivering poor outcomes
for students
to that Republicans have offered to work
yeah I'll be very quick Republicans have
offered to work with the president on
measures to combat this the actual cost
of education is the president willing to
work with the Republicans on that do you
believe that the Republicans are sincere
look I think that the president has a
long track record of working with
Democrats and Republicans for getting
things done for middle-class families he
did it a number of times in the first
two years in office if it comes to real
serious uh reforms to the cost of higher
education that aren't going to cut off
Pathways for middle-class families and
where the costs of that aren't being
placed on middle-class families then I
think that the president is willing to
work with anybody who has good ideas on
that in that
regardless of how did the student debt
relief program as a tool to close the
racial wealth Gap without it does the
White House believe that his economic
policies can still achieve that goal or
that these new actions can help yeah one
of the many reasons why we're continuing
to pursue this alternative pathway is
because the president feels very
strongly that we need to take steps to
close to that racial wealth Gap in
America you're right that the initial
debt relief program would have made real
strides in that uh in that area and our
goal with providing a debt relief to
borrowers as many borrowers as we can as
quickly as we can is to to do that as
well I mean I don't have to tell you but
I think we've uh
we have seen the data about the
disparate impact of student loan debt
right that black borrowers tend to have
to borrow more often for going to school
that they have to borrow more because
they tend to have less family wealth to
rely upon and it takes them longer to
repay after they graduate because again
they have less family wealth to rely
upon in fact there's data showing that
many black borrowers in addition to
having to repay their own loans because
they had opportunity to go to college or
helping other people and their family
pay off their debts whereas for other
types of borrowers they're getting
family assistance to pay off their own
loans so there's a really serious issue
here that's one of the many reasons why
the president pursued this debt relief
path and why he is continuing to pursue
this alternative pathway now
I wanted to give that affordability
issue um so does the president then
blame universities for that
affordability issue and do you really
think that that Rule's working that you
talked about well the rule is still in
progress It's going to be proposed and
then ultimately put in place but I think
when it is in place it's definitely
going to go after the the worst
performers in this space the the
colleges and universities that are
charging the most and delivering the
worst results
I think other reforms are necessary the
president's willing to work with
Congress to talk through what those may
be but as we said there's another goal
here which is to ease some of that cost
in the in the meantime for lower income
and middle-income families who are
trying to send their kid to school and
that's what the Pell Grant does and and
I would just note that
not so long ago the Pell Grant typical
Pell Grant covered about 75 percent of
the cost of college now it covers way
less than half the cost of college it
has been devalued over time and that's
one of the reasons why the president's
been aggressive about increasing the
size of the Pell Grant the Department of
Education is a pre-approved 16 million
people for for the forgiveness program
was that meant to put political pressure
on the court because you knew that this
was going through the court process you
didn't have a decision yet and we're
government resources then wasted on this
no I think we explained to borrowers
what the process is going to be we're
going to set up this website as soon as
you send us your information people
behind the scenes at the department are
going to be working extremely quickly to
validate your information and to decide
whether you're approved or not that's
exactly what we did the court
unfortunately the the lower court in
this case stepped in before we could
actually take that final step and
actually discharge debt for Approved
borrowers but
when the court process was happening we
didn't have an answer right but we
didn't know what that the court was
going to enjoin us from actually doing
debt relief that was still an open
question at the time we had an
obligation to borrowers uh to keep
moving with the process as long as we
legally could
and I want to make one one more Point
here because the debt relief program was
announced alongside if you remember a
resumption in payments so we had a
student loan pause in effect in August
the president announced that we were
going to have this debt relief as a
lead-in to student loan payments
resuming in January of this year and so
there was a time pressure on us to make
sure that borrowers who are applying
were getting their debt relief quickly
before they had that obligation to start
making payments because of course that
discharge relief could mean that their
payments would go down when they had to
start making payments again
uh first the other day the president
said that this is not a normal Court
while the administration disagrees with
this decision does the administration
think that it is legitimate and then
second is it the comparison between
student loans and the paycheck
Protection Program a little bit strained
given that some of those federal student
loans were given with the expectation
that they would be paid back and then
the paycheck Protection Program loans
were given to employers with the
expectation that those loans will be
forgiven if they kept folks on payroll
during a pandemic yeah so on your first
question you know we accept the Court's
ruling of course we disagree with it you
know we had a chance to review the
dissent written by Justice Kagan we
largely agree with the points that were
made uh in The Descent
you know in terms of the PPP analogy
I think that this is the the big picture
here as the as we went through the
pandemic there were a variety of
programs put in place to help certain
subsets of the population and one of the
biggest programs that was put in place
was PPP that was intended to help small
business owners right and um and I think
that we have uh gone through with those
loan forgivenesses as the president has
said 780 billion dollars worth of uh of
loan forgiveness but I think that the
real hypocrisy in his view is that a lot
of that loan forgiveness was happening
over the last year year and a half
and at any time all of the republicans
in Congress who were saying to us this
debt relief program is unacceptable
could have also been saying hey take it
easy on doing all this debt forgiveness
you know a lot of these small business
owners actually did really well in the
pandemic shouldn't we take a second look
at whether all of these loans should be
forgiven they're costing taxpayers
hundreds of billions of dollars and we
never got a single uh bit of incoming
from Republicans saying slow down PPP
forgiveness in fact the incoming we got
was people saying do it faster
make it easier for people to qualify for
forgiveness so yeah we think that
there's a real tension between that and
the idea that if we're going to try and
give ten thousand dollars to a nurse or
a firefighter uh that that somehow is uh
unacceptable or crosses the line from
acceptable government relief to
unacceptable government belief ebony
ebony
you have the last question thank you
you mentioned that there were a number
of things that you were considering
um
but but you said why you went with the
two that that you did my question is if
you don't get the projected outcome that
you want which you haven't said what
that number is are there a number of
other measures that you are considering
like either whether it's canceling some
of the interests or looking at the pslf
maybe changing even some of the in some
of the jobs that will be required for
that or any other measures if this
doesn't give you the desired outcome
yeah I want to make clear that we're
moving out on multiple fronts so today
we announced two new steps right we
announced pursuing The Higher Education
Act rulemaking process and we announced
the 12-month on-ramp to repayment the
changes to Public service loan
forgiveness they're already taking place
as the secretary pointed out up until
this Administration something like 7 000
people total had gotten Public service
loan forgiveness even though you had
teachers and members service members who
had met the requirements they weren't
able to get their relief we have taken
incredible steps to fix that program and
now 600 000 people have gotten that
relief so we're moving out on the pslf
front we're moving out on the
income-based repayment front remember
this is going to be a massive savings
for
a lot of borrowers your typical borrower
saving a thousand dollars a year uh on
their repayment and by the way there's
some changes in in that program as well
such that if you are have lower amounts
of debt like you went to a community
college you're actually on a faster
Pathway to getting your loans forgiven
such that the typical Community College
student is going to get their loans
forgiven within 10 years so we're as
secretary Cardona said there has never
been a president and there's never been
an Administration that has come close to
providing the support and relief for
student loan borrowers that this
Administration has and we're committed
to doing that because student loan
borrowers are the types of middle class
folks that this President thinks are
really important to this economy doing
well to take it back to the question
about biodynamics when we talk about
growing the economy from the bottom up
in the middle out that's what this
relief program was about 90 of it went
to people making under seventy five
thousand dollars a year and now that's
been ripped away
we're not going to stand for that we're
not going to let that lie as it is we're
going to move forward on every other
pathway we can to get those middle class
folks their relief
for pslf
for the new
release so if you go to studentaid.gov
you'll see uh FAQs about some of the
steps that we're taking all right thanks
thanks thank you so much
take a few more since it's after five
o'clock on a Friday Colleen
let's keep going oh yeah why not
um okay I have a question about the
court release this week so if this if
the Supreme Court doesn't reflect the
views of the American people like Biden
has said should he be embracing a
proposal to change the court
so look I just wanna
uh as you know and I talked about this a
little bit during the Gaggle yesterday
which was uh you all were asking me
about the commission that the president
was very proud uh to put together it was
diverse it had legal voices from the
right from the left uh and uh it was
something that you had never seen before
and it was incredibly important the
president thought was to do and
obviously he read the report
um don't have any don't have any uh
decisions to to lay out at this time so
certainly not going to get ahead of the
president I know people have asked about
expanding the court he's been very clear
that's not something that he wants to do
as it relates to that look the president
is certainly has made himself very clear
about how he sees these Court decision
and the rate the reason why he said that
is it's pretty clear right when you
think about the Dobbs decision when you
think about Roe v Wade this is something
that was constitutional for almost 50
years almost 50 years uh and uh you know
some of these decisions on these big of
items that have been reversed were
decided by both Republicans and
Democrats right and so that is uh that
is not the norm when you reverse
something that was almost 50 years you
think about affirmative action also and
the president said this yesterday
decades decades uh again decided by
Republicans and Democrats and so that
has been uh reversed so you know I I'm
not going to go beyond what the
president said but if you laid that out
that's pretty clear and this is also a
president that was the chair of the
Judiciary Committee right when he was
sent when he was a Senator right who was
able who understands this process
respects this process is an expert in
this process so when you have someone
with like the president who has this
experience and says that you know he's
not saying it because it's a feeling
he's saying it because he has seen this
over and over a year over and over over
the decades and how a Supreme Court have
acted and how they taken action and so
you know uh
don't have anything beyond what the
president said yesterday and what he has
said many times about when he's been
asked directly about the court but it's
you know I laid out for the American
people and they can see themselves and
and make their decisions for themselves
thank you so much Karine I hope you two
questions I want to follow up a little
bit on that uh these decisions of the
Supreme Court here have big big
repercussions in other countries some
are accessing
um implications on their own societies
so do you have any message to those
countries watching what is taking place
here and uh on yesterday's uh the
president comments that this is not a
normal Port does it have any solution
for that what is uh what can he do
so look um one of the things that the
president has done since the beginning
of this Administration is make sure that
he put nominees forward in the judicial
when you think about judicial level
right the federal court that are that is
diverse he's gotten 136 uh people
through nominees through and we're
talking about a diverse candidate that
reflect and you heard you hear this over
and over from us right we wanted an
Administration that includes the court
that looks like America and that's what
this president has done and I think
that's an action that he has been very
deliberate about uh very very methodical
about so that we can have a court system
that is reflective a court system that
is fair a court system that is diverse
and so that is an action that he has
taken again almost from day one
another question about the news breaking
news today today the Brazil Electro
Court voted to ban former president
bolsonaro from running for office for
eight years uh because of his election
fraud claim uh I wonder if you guys have
any reaction to that so obviously we've
seen the reports we just don't have a
comment at this time
the statement a couple minutes ago
criticizing the administration for only
releasing 24 of the 87 pages of the
Afghanistan after action report and
saying this is another blatant attempt
to hide The Binding administration's
culpability in the chaotic and deadly
evacuation from Afghanistan so yeah a
couple things I have not seen his
statement since you just said it
happened a couple minutes ago so I want
to be mindful I don't like to respond to
things I haven't seen But first I would
say I refer you to the state department
they released this uh this report this
report so any specific questions that
you have certainly would refer you there
but more broadly on the transparency
question look this Administration has
consistently provided updates
information on the withdrawal from
Afghanistan we have provided that
information anytime that we've been
asked we have done so and a couple of
examples is thousands of pages of
documents thousands of pages of
documents and Analysis spreadsheets and
written responses to questions that we
have received that we have gotten from
the committee from from Congress
hundreds of briefings to bipart Artisan
members and staff public Congressional
testimony that many of you have covered
and and uh and talked about these have
been done by senior officials so when
you look at those and that's just the
facts that's the data that tells you how
transparent and how responsive uh this
Administration has been anything related
to the release from the state department
any specifics I certainly would refer
you to them
is from Republic
tried to downplay its culpability in the
evacuation Mayhem and the things that
went wrong as the U.S was pulling out
what message does it send to release
this long anticipated report on a Friday
on a heavy news day I have a holiday
again that is the state department
decision so I would have to refer you to
them but your first question your first
part of the question right we were you
were talking about transparency I just
laid out thousands of pages of documents
just laying it out analysis just laying
it out spreadsheets just laying it out
responses to questions where
well I I disagree with the premise but
I'm also laying out what we've actually
done right we've actually laid out and
have conversation you've seen uh senior
officials take questions tough questions
in a bipartisan way on this issue and
we've we've delivered on hundreds and
hundreds thousands upon me of pages of
information hundreds of briefings so
that's being transparent that's being
there and answering and taking those
tough questions and so uh yeah I
disagree with the premise the premise of
the question but again I just lay out
the facts for you and it's been there
it's for all of you to see go ahead
can you just on the report has the
president reviewed it or been briefed on
it he was just asked about it in the
Roosevelt room and he said read your
press and I wasn't really clear what
what he was trying to say there well I
didn't I didn't hear I know that he was
asked about the uh about about this
particular uh review or this action uh
after action review that was was uh
given look what I can speak to is more
broadly what the president has said and
I think this is what he was referring to
he had to make a tough decision right in
the beginning of his administration he
had to make a tough decision on what to
do with the Nations within the nation's
longest war right where we were seeing
uh you know billions of dollars go into
a war that had no end in sight where our
our members of the military were put at
risk and so he wanted to stop that he
wanted to end that and he also wanted to
and this is part of what he said at the
end which is he wanted to make sure that
we remain Vigilant against terrorism and
that's what he was laying out right the
threats that that they were that have
been demonstrated and so uh we took as
you know we took a leader of al-Qaeda
without having any troops any troops on
the ground and so that's what he was
talking about is keeping our promise
making sure that we keep Americans safe
making sure that we make sure that we we
put the American people's interests
first and so that's what you've seen
this president do the report
specifically says that senior
Administration officials were to blame
for the chaotic exit for failing to
decide which Afghans should be eligible
eligible for evacuation and for issuing
changing guidance do you agree with the
report do you accept responsibility what
I'm saying the report came from the
state department is that action after
action report I will just let it speak
for itself I'm just not going to comment
further this is a state department
report clearly it is part of the
administration if that's what it lays
out that's what it lays out good good
get help from the Taliban okay you had
the Supreme Court ruling yesterday on
College admissions the rulings today two
things how do you view this as a whole
how big a setback business to the
president's agenda I mean look the
president has been really clear heard
from the secretary you heard from the
president we're going to continue to
fight we think the Supreme Court got it
wrong we've been very clear about that
this is you know when you think more
broadly about
um especially student loan uh the
student debt relief and what the
president put forward this is part of a
little bit of what uh Barat was talking
about this is part of binomics right
this is part of what the president has
been trying to do for the last two years
which is give the American people a
little bit more relief and you see that
it has worked we think about 13 million
jobs created when you think about
unemployment rate at below four percent
these are the things because of the
action that this president has taken has
worked and it started with the American
Rescue plan you saw the bipartisan
infrastructure legislation the inflation
reduction Act and the student debt
relief is all part of that there are
real people across the country who are
still suffering who need a little bit of
help you know when uh when the secretary
started he gave a very passionate intro
about who who would have been benefited
from this debt relief and it is 90 right
90 percent of the people in that plan
who make seventy five thousand dollars
or less would have benefited and the
president talked about this too why
would we not want to give relief to
those people and it is unfortunate that
Republicans think the that that they
don't need relief and it's we're talking
about people in their own district and
so that is what is truly disappointing
about that but it's not going to set us
back it's it's a setback for the moment
but it's not going to set back the
president's broader plan and how he sees
uh building uh the economy not leaving
anybody behind and not doing a trickle
uh trickle down but actually doing it
with with building out the the middle
the building up the middle class and
doing it from the bottom up and that's
the president's commitment to this okay
go ahead
and set back in number for the national
archivist to release the remaining
records of the JFK's assassination
the president been updated about the
progress what is the remaining number of
records that will remain classified yeah
so I do have an update for you uh as
part of the by and Harris
administration's continued commitment to
government transparency accountability
the president President Biden issued a
memorandum today concluding the review
of records from the President John from
President John F Kennedy assassination
records collection under President
Biden's leadership agencies have fully
Declassified over 16 000 records since
2021 this action reflects his
instruction that all information related
to President Kennedy's assassination
should be released except when the
strongest possible reasons Council
otherwise as a result over 99 percent of
the records in the collection are now
publicly available at the national
archives in keeping with the president's
Direction the National Archives will be
digitizing the entire collection to make
it more accessible to the public any any
other specifics or any additional
information I certainly will refer you
to the National Archives to have uh to
answer any additional questions on this
but that was done
get Michael that's great I'm 303
creative
what is an expressive original design
say that one more time
do you have a sense a clear sense of who
this actually impacts his decision today
I mean I don't have like a number or a
list of who of of
um uh of of who this is going to impact
what we know and understand is this was
uh this was a the wrong decision this
was incredibly disappointing that
decision was made it's certainly going
to impact for sure the lgbtq plus
Community it opens up uh it opens up an
entry a pathway for for that Community
to be even more discriminated upon and
so after you've seen this type of uh you
know State House session where we see
more than 600
anti-lgbtq plus bills including a few
hundred that go after trans kids and
their parents it is incredibly
disappointing it is incredibly
disappointing this is a vulnerable
Community along with others that have
been under attack under attack and so uh
the president we saw the president's
statement he's been very clear about
this we do have our concerns and we're
certainly going to call it out we have
said very I said very clearly that we're
going to continue to push for the
equality act which we think is
incredibly important that Congress
should act on that and so look we're
going to do everything that we can to
protect these vulnerable communities as
the president has been doing since
daylight
Court tries to distinguish in its
decision and enforce it just decision
between a service and an expressive
desire and I'm just trying to get a
sense of if you feel like you understand
that so I hear you I'm just not going to
get into specifics more broadly this is
a problem right this is clear
discriminate this is going to clearly
open another Avenue another door to
discriminating against a vulnerable
community and so the president is going
to continue to enforce Federal
anti-discrimination protections and he's
going to call on Congress to move
forward with the equality act and that's
what I think the American people need to
hear that's what the community need to
hear that we're going to do everything
that we can to protect them
all right I'm going to take one last
question and try and call somebody I
haven't called them
I mean I don't have anything else to add
on Afghanistan
I literally just I literally just
answered that question to your colleague
and trying to explain to you where I
thought he was coming from I literally
just went into that okay good good just
a follow-up and another question after
that follow-up to the discussion about
the racial wealth Gap and the burden of
student loan debt on um
African-Americans especially black women
the United Negro College Fund is asking
for the Pell Grants to be doubled
because students at historically black
colleges and universities qualify for
that nearly nearly three out of four of
them qualify for that is this something
the administration is willing to push
Congress to do well I think that's a
little bit of what Barat was saying when
he was up here what the president has
done he he did expand the Pell Grant
right remember he was talking about it
used to cover about 50 or more and now
it's lost it's gotten devalued and so
one of the things that the president did
very early on is to expand the Pell
Grant uh and especially for
African-American communities and
communities that really need that extra
help and so that is something that we
have done and look not going to not
going to talk specifically about other
things that we're going to do outside of
the plan that the president announced
outside of the the uh the details that
both the secretary and and also Bharat
spoke to but this is something we
understand the the uh the inequalities
right that we see in the in this country
that still exist the president talked
about that in his remarks on affirmative
action this is a real thing that
communities have to deal with and so
this is a president everything that he
has done every policy especially as we
talk about the economy at the center of
that has always been Equity always been
equality making sure we leave no one
behind and we build an economy that that
is different that is not trickle-down
economics that is something that we
build from the bottom up middle out and
we and also expand in the middle class
and that's something that the
president's going to continue to do all
right everybody
what's your second question
Republicans for doing everything in
their power to block the student loan
forgiveness program but this was
ultimately the Supreme Court's decision
why the blame on Republicans well the
Republicans during the budget
negotiations as you all know they try to
strip they try to take away that was
something that they wanted to put on The
Chopping box was the student debt relief
they were very clear about that and so
what the president did was protect it
and that was something that he bought
just a couple months ago and he's been
fighting for this since he announced the
student to student debt relief plan so
yes Republicans have been wanting to get
rid of this plan again something is a
plan that's going to give relief to 90
percent of the folks make less than 75
000 why would we not want to offer that
up that relief to people who truly truly
need it especially after going through
what folks have gone through the last
three years this pandemic that has hurt
so many families and so you know that's
just the fact that's what we had to
fight for now we do think the Supreme
Court got it wrong and it is unfortunate
which is why we came up with a plan B
and we're going to execute on that plan
thanks everybody happy fourth